je m'appelle mathieu j'ai fait le tour
n'a de judo a dû en cours j'ai une
nouvelle ceinture comme mathieu une
centaine de judokas âgés de 4 à 12 ans
participé ce dimanche ont joint au
traditionnel tournoi des samouraïs à
guyancourt
une compétition organisée chaque année à
la fin de l'année scolaire par le club
local au gymnase des droits de l'homme
l'idée là en fait pour
remerciez est récompensée au moyen du
passage de grade de ceinture supérieure
les élèves qui ont été les plus assidus
qui ont eu des résultats en compétitions
tout au long de l'année les compétitions
qu'on fait nous dans les yvelines
on récompense aussi
quelques élèves vraiment élus triés sur
le volet en récompense pour leur
assiduité leur concentration bien
qu'amical esprit de compétition était
bien présent chez les petits judokas
tous ont voulu enchaîner les ippons et
les wazari pendant leur combat à la fin
de la journée les organisateurs ont
récompensé les meilleurs sportifs avec
des médailles y être gagnés tous vers
l'acquis et j'ai fait très jerry plus
c'est bien quand on gagne mais quand on
perd c'est aussi parce qu'on l'a soit
des adversaires plus forts ou soit parce
qu'on n'a pas bien combattu rendez vous
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition le tournoi des samouraïs but en
cours et une histoire qui dure depuis
une vingtaine d'amis